a
[Música]
ah
el pasado 21 de octubre españa superó la
barrera simbólica de los más de 1 millón
de casos detectados de coronavirus sin
embargo esta cifra está lejos de lo que
es la realidad y es que ya en la pasada
primavera
analistas de la universidad carlos
tercero realizaron un estudio de cero
prevalencia y estimaron que por entonces
se habían ya infectado 2,5 millones de
españoles mientras la cifra oficial se
situaba en torno a los 250 mil eso es un
10 por ciento y desde ese momento el
ministerio de sanidad estima que se
detectan entre el 60 y el 80 por ciento
de los casos por lo que las estimaciones
actuales comprenden que entre 3,5 y 5
millones de españoles se habrían
infectado ya por coronavirus desde el
inicio de la pandemia sin embargo este
decalaje no es exclusivo de españa y es
que la organización mundial de la salud
ya apunto a principios de octubre que un
10 por ciento de la población mundial se
habría infectado esto es 700 millones de
personas lejos también de la cifra
oficial que se sitúa en la actualidad
por encima de los 40 millones
[Música]
francia sobrepasó el millón de casos
acumulados de kobe 19 es el segundo país
de europa en sobrepasar este récord
después de españa la situación sanitaria
sigue desmejorando y de hecho la
atención en los centros hospitalarios es
cada vez mayor además de esto pues la
velocidad con la que viene propagándose
esta segunda ola tiene muy sorprendidos
a los miembros del consejo científico
ese consejo que asesora al gobierno
nacional desde el comienzo de esta
epidemia para ellos pues no son ni 40
mil y 50 mil los casos diarios sino
cerca de 100.000 ya que no se están
contabilizando ni los asintomáticos ni
los casos no diagnosticados para frenar
la epidemia el gobierno decretó un toque
de queda en buena parte de su territorio
46 millones de personas se ven afectadas
por esta medida una medida que va a ser
evaluada esta semana última semana de
octubre según lo indicó el y goma el
ministro de salud y en caso de no estar
dando los frutos suficientes pues ya son
cada vez más las voces que piden un
nuevo confinamiento
[Música]
doble récord este fin de semana para
colombia por un lado se llegó al millón
de contagios por kobe 19 y por otra
parte se superaron las 30.000 muertes
por el virus
colombia es el octavo país del mundo en
número de contagios y el tercer país con
más casos de américa latina después de
brasil y argentina- sin embargo ocupa la
quinta posición en la región si se
tienen en cuenta los positivos por
millón de habitantes colombia vivió un
confinamiento precoz desde el 24 de
marzo cuando el país tenía sólo 3
muertes y poco más de 300 casos una
previsión que le permitió equipar
unidades de cuidados intensivos y
recibir insumos médicos para enfrentar
la pandemia de este modo en colombia no
se vieron las imágenes de
sobresaturación del sistema de salud que
se vieron al principio de la pandemia en
europa y aunque el kobe 19 no ha dejado
de avanzar la curva ha sido mucho más
estable sin embargo aunque la capital
bogotá ya ha pasado el primer pico la
segunda ciudad del país que en medellín
comienza a ver sus unidades de cuidados
intensivos saturadas por encima de un 80
por ciento
[Música]